ل
75 عام من الاحتلال والجرائم والظلم هذا
الطوفان ينبع من الاقتيات في دير ياسين
وكفر قاسم استهداف الش الشهداء الشباب
الفلسطينيين من
قبل جيوش ومن العناصر
الصهيونيه عام 45 تشنها
بمساعده الداعمين طوفان الاقصى هو
حاصل لاستهداف الفلسطينيين في النقاط
المختلفه على يد
شارون المجرم من قبل
وه
نتيجه الاحتلال
ونزوح للشعب
الفلسطيني كانت رد فعل وجواب للاهانات
التي يقوم
بها الصهاينه ل اقصى اقتحام منازل
المسلمين في الضفه الغربيه كان جوابا لكل
هذه
الامور وكانت
عمليه
شققه انفجار
ل
عاهم اتصال اعتقا دار
و جبهه المقاومه طبعا متصله ببعضها وه ذو
ق
وشعار مش
مشتر لها اشتراكات كثه ل كل
رن المقاومه ومحور المقاومه يخلق ح
هناك جبهه مقاومه
عامه عنوانها الجهان عفوا العالم
الاسلام و
تربطها القيم و العقيده لكن انصار الله
لها محورها ولها قرارها هي مستقله ونحن
لا نتدخل في شانهم هم اصحاب القرار هم
اصحاب السلطه هم من يقررون
لانفسهم المقاومه في العراق لديها هويه
عراقيه رغم انها متصله
بال محور المقاومه بشكل عام لكنها مستقله
بقرارها وعملياتها وهي من تقرر لنفسها هي
صاحبه القرار في لبنان حزب الله ايضا كذلك
صحيح
انه
متصل عقيده وايمانا وقيما
بال مقاومه محور المقاومه بشكل عام لكن
حزب الله مستقل ويقرر حسب مصالح الشعب
الفلسطيني وطبعا يدعم المظلومين في العالم
الاسلامي نحن
در
كن فلسط
حت اخر لحظه ندعم القضيه الفلسطين وندعم
الشعب الفلسطيني الله
ات م بر آمر
م
اسل آنه سخنو سه ما من صرح به المتحدث
المتحدث باسم حرس
الثوره تحدثت اليه هاتفيا اقول اليوم
ليعلم العالم اجمع اننا نحن صادق بقولنا
وفعلنا نحن منظمه قو و هوا بدون سرن آمر
را زم عندما استهدفنا
الطائره بدون طيار الامريكيه اعلنا ذلك
شن هجوما على عين الاسد او ارب
استهدفنا الوكر
الصهيوني اعلنا ذلك وتبني العمليات نحن
نتبنى العمليات التي نقوم بها لا نخاف ولا
نهاب اي
عدو اخبرني انن استخدمت هذه
العباره
اقصد القول
ان انج الطبيعي لطوفان
الاقصى
هو حاج قام نتجه بود
اننت ار القول انها ناتجه عن ذلك
وليست المحفز لعمليه طوفان الاقصى لذا
اعلن للعالم ان طوفان الاقصى عمليه
فلسطينيه بحته هي قا على هذه العمليه
وقامت
بها حماس
وجهاد في
غزه ينتجون الاسلحه ويقومون بالمقاومه كل
شهيد يسقط يقوم بدل منه عشرات المجاهدين
هم مستمرون في هذه الحرب وهم يستطيعون
الاستمرار ونحن نعلم ان هذه المقاومه ليس
لها
و
طاقت ر صون برا
امهار ماته وبدد
هو قدره الكيان الصهيوني في مجابهه هذه
المقاومه هذا ما سينتهي وسيهزم
[موسيقى]
الفلسط في غزه
هم علموا نموذج وعلم
طقه جهاد وعلموا طقه الجهاد الله علمهم
والهمهم ذلك
هم
جرب الطرق المختلفه مع الكيان الصهيوني
واليوم الكان الصهيوني يتحمل هزائم كثيره
من
قبل آد تا در
اره حول
مس
امر اقم
انفسهم اراض الاخر
و احتلالهم لاراضي الشعوب
الاخرى لن يسمحوا لهم الشعب لن يسمح لهم
بذلك اليوم الان الصهيون جيشه اقتصاده وحت
شعبه نهار وهزم ت ش ازد استرو ش بالنسبه
للمقاومه الشهاده هي احدى الحسنيين
اما
هم منصر منطق غزه
بومت هم مادان غزه تجاهد وتقاوم بهذا
المنطق ونحن نعلم
ان قريبا وعاجلا سدها سم رفع ش تارخ
بشر اجمل نشيد لتاريخ
البشريه واعداء الاسلام
[موسيقى]
مد
الحرب را اعدا الاسلام الذين اضطروا الى
استهداف الشهيد رضي
موسوي هذا يدل على ضعف وانهيار الكان
الصهيوني في الوقت الحالي مقابل
[موسيقى]
ش من هنا اننا لن نصمت على استهداف
واستشهاد ابناء هذا الوطن انتقام
س
ج ر صون از صه وج وانتقام لدماء الشهد رض
موسوي لن يكون غير انهاء الكان
الصهيوني
منف جغرا
س اسمهم
المف الصفحه السياسيه للعالم بجهاد
المقاومين
الفلسطينيين
و
مقاومتهم